[موسيقى]
رئيس اعرفه على مدار سنوات وهو رجل
تكوينه عسكري وهو جنرال في الجيش وهو مسيس
وكان وزير الاول وليس جمهوريه منتخب مهما
قيل في الانتخابات
وبالتالي
وكل ما نعرفه انه هرب كما قيل يعني ليست
لدينا اي معلومات عن كيف خرج هل كان ذلك
عنوه
هل وقعت خيانه هل هنالك شيء من هذا
اللحظه
لانني لا اتصور في ذهني ان رجلا عليه عرفه
جيدا في في قلب الازمه
ويغادر او كما يقولوا بعض الناس يعني يخلق
المكان
[موسيقى]
ماذا قصد الرئيس التونسي الاسبق زين
العابدين بن علي عندما نقل اليك عبر صديقه
لانه غدر عن الوطن
ان يغادر بنفسه هل اجبر على ذلك اذا
لم يوضح يا صديقه استعمل انه لم يغادر من
تلقائي نفسه انه لم
يتخذ القرار الذي كيف غادر الله اعلم
روايه ليست امامي مدعمتها الحقيقيه
ليله طرابلسي زوجه الرئيس او ارمله الرئيس
الان كانت غمزت من قناه علي السوري
بعد تخويفه من ان المظاهرات قادمه وان قد
يتم ما لا يحمد عقبه
اتهم الجميع في ذلك كل من كان له صله
الشان الامني والامن الرئاسي الى اخره
اتهموه واتهموا بعضهم البعض ولذلك لا يمكن
ان نقول ان فلانا او فلتانه
[موسيقى]